The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help MIT Open
Courseware continue to
offer high-quality educational
resources for free.
To make a donation or view
additional materials from
hundreds of MIT courses, visit
MIT Open Courseware at
ocw.mit.edu.
Hi I'm Sal.
Today we're going to solve
problem number 6 of
exam 1 of fall 2009.
Now before you attempt a
problem, there are a lot of
things that you should know,
that is background material
that's going to help you
solve the problem.
Especially during an exam,
given that this was the
hardest on this exam.
So you should be able to
finish this within
15 minutes or so.
So before you start the problem
you should know what
the energy is of a charged
particle in an electric field,
which is given by
this equation.
The conversion from an electron
volt to a joule,
which is just a conversion of
energy and this should be
given to you on your
table of constants.
Also the energy associated with
an emission spectrum,
which is given by this equation
where k is actually
the ionization energy of
hydrogen, which is 13.6
electron volts and the z squared
is the atomic number
of your atom of interest. And
then the n f and the n sub i
are your transition states.
The DeBroglie wavelength, which
is given by lambda, is
equal to a Planck's Constant
divided by the momentum.
And always remember that you
need to conserve energy.
This is what's going
to get you the full
points on the problem.
So the problem, it's best to
solve if you draw a little
image as you read the problem.
So the problem reads, atoms of
ionized helium gas, He plus,
are struck by electrons in a gas
discharge tube operating
with the potential difference
between the
electrodes set at 8.8 volts.
So I'm going to go ahead and
start drawing an image.
So let's say I have two plates
where the voltage between
these two is set
at 8.88 volts.
And what's happening here is
that you're accelerating
electrons through here.
So you can imagine that--
say this is positively
charges and this
is negatively charged--
that an electron starts from
your negative plate and then
it accelerates toward your
positive plate and you can
imagine your plate having hole
or something small where your
electron can then exit and then
be in free space under
the influence of no potential.
So then these electrons are
actually being aimed towards
your helium plus ions.
So that's your target.
Now if I continue reading the
problem, it says that the
emmision spectrum includes the
line associated with the
transition from n equals
3 to n equals 2.
Calculate the minimum value of
the DeBroglie wavelength of
scattered electrons that have
collided with helium plus and
generated this line in the
emission spectrum.
So it's an energy conservation
problem.
And all this tells you is that,
you have an electron
that is being accelerated
through your potential.
The electron is going to strike
a helium plus atom and
upon that you detect an
emission spectrum.
Well what does that tell you?
That tells you that that
electron actually excited an
electron in the atom.
The electron had to transition
to a higher state to absorb
energy and then decay and in
the process of decaying it
emits a photon, which
is what you detect.
So this information
is given to you.
But the problem asks to find
the value of the DeBroglie
wavelength.
So since this an energy
conservation problem, and this
is the very first step that
happens and I know that my
energy equation for a
charged particle is
simply q times the voltage.
So I know that q, which is a
certain value of charge, the
product of these two when I'm
multiplying by 8.8 volts, this
yields 8.88 electron volts.
So it's a new unit of energy
where we just saw the
conversion.
And the reason why this takes
this shape is because one
electron has the charge of 1.6
times 10 to the negative 19
coulombs and that's where the
conversion from electrical
volts to joules come from.
So I'm going to go ahead and
call this e sub i initial.
Because this is our initial
energy that we're given.
So we just start with this
energy, nothing else.
Nothing else was given
from the problem.
So we want to go ahead
and conserve this.
So our final state, the
combination of whatever we are
solving, should not have a
higher energy than what
initially we started with.
So because the problem says
that we have an emission
spectrum, I'm going to go ahead
and draw another image.
I'll label this one,
initial and I'll
label this one, final.
So my final image, you can
imagine a helium plus atom.
And the electron strikes the
helium plus atom and we detect
a photon and you're getting
a scattered electron.
That's what the problem says.
Scattered electron.
So what this tells me is that
this energy now is going into
creating a photon and
scattering an
electron from your atom.
So if I was to equate those two
or what not I can already
say that, well in my final state
I detect an emission or
an emission spectrum.
And I know what the
transition says.
It goes from n equals
3 to n equals 2.
That's what the problem
tells us.
So if I take my equation, my
delta e of my emission
spectrum, is simply going to be
negative k, which is 13.6
electron volts.
And I'm going to multiply
by the atomic
number, squared now.
This is where people also make
mistakes during the exam.
The atomic number is not 1.
It's actually 2 because we're
talking about helium.
And the atomic number is not
the number of electrons or
values in terms of an ion, but
it's actually the number of
protons that you have. So
helium has 2 protons.
So I can multiply this by 2.
And I'm going to square it.
And I know that I'm going from
n and equals 3 to n equals 2.
So if I plug this into my
equation I have 1 over 3
squared minus 1 over 2 squared,
which is 9 and 4.
And if you plug this in, and
assuming that your calculator
works and is correct, you get a
value of 7.56 electron volts
because that was the unit
that I was using.
Everything else is unitless,
so my energy is now 7.56
electron volts for
my transition.
Which covers this part
for my photon.
So now we're left with what
the energy of this is.
So what is the energy of
the scattered electron?
Well if I equate the initial to
the final I know that the
final is a composition
of the transition
in my scatter state.
So I know that e initial, which
is 8.88 electron volts,
this equals to the energy for
the emission spectrum, which
is 7.56 electron volts.
So I'll put the units in square
brackets so you don't
get confused.
And then plus the energy of
the scattered electron.
So if I subtract the two,
I get the energy of
my scattered electron.
And that pretty much gives
me a value of--
after I subtract that--
e of scattered electron
is equal to--
well the distance between these
two is actually 1.32
electron volts.
But don't stop here because the
problem didn't ask you to
figure out the energy of
the scattered electron.
It actually told us to figure
out what the DeBroglie
wavelength is of this
scattered electron.
Now the fact that the electron
is scattered, to me that means
that the only energy
that this particle
has is kinetic energy.
So it's a classical
form of energy.
So I can go ahead and I can
equate this to just 1/2 mass
of the electrons times my
velocity squared-- whatever
velocity it has.
Now I'd don't need to figure
out what the velocity is.
This is just important to figure
out what the DeBroglie
wavelength is.
So this is good.
Now if we look at what our
DeBroglie wavelength is, we
know that lambda is
equal to Planck's
Constant divided by p.
And Planck's Constant has a
value of 6.6 times 10 to the
minus 34 with units
of joules seconds.
So this is important too.
Always keep track of your units
because dimensional
analysis will help you a lot
when solving these problems. A
lot of the times you're given
energy values in electron
volts but your solution will
have a constant that doesn't
have an electron volt, that will
have a joule, so you're
forced to make that conversion
or else your problem is going
to be wrong.
OK so with that in mind,
we know what h is.
But what about p?
Well p is momentum.
And classical momentum is just
mass times your velocity.
So this is just mass times
velocity, but this is the mass
times our velocity.
We know what the mass
of the election is.
That's given on our table
of constants.
But the velocity, we don't know
what it is but we can
grab it from our classical
energy.
So if I look at my energy--
from the side so I'm going
to look at my energy--
I know that my energy--
I'm going to call this
scat, for scattered--
the energy of my scattered
electron is simply 1/2 the
mass of the electron times
our velocity squared.
Now if I multiply both sides by
2m, I'm going to go ahead
and get us to the point where I
can get an equation that is
just my mass times v.
So I'm going to multiply both
sides by 2m, So I get 2 mass
of the electron, e scat of
the electron, equals--
if I multiply this by
2m, the two cancel,
so I get an m squared.
m squared times v squared
is essentially
just m times v squared.
And this becomes just mass of
your electron v squared.
Now if I take the square root
of both sides, I end up
getting a nice relation
for just m times v.
So I know that m times v now is
just simply equal to this--
canceled, the square root
cancels the square.
The square root of 2 mass of the
electron times the energy
of the scattered electron.
So if I go back to my DeBroglie
wavelength, I have m v.
So I can take that value as a
function of energy and just
substitute it into
my equation.
And that'll help us get the
answer because we know what
the energy of the scattered
electron is.
We calculated that on
the first part.
So with that in mind we'll
come over here.
Again this is 6.6 times
10 to the minus 34.
And the units are
joules seconds.
And down here I have the square
root of 2 times my mass
of the electron, which is on
your table of constants.
And it's just 9.11 times
10 to the minus 31.
And this has units of kilograms.
And the energy of
my scattered electron, which
is 1.3 times 1.32 and this
units of electron volts.
Now this has units of
electron volts.
This has units of joules.
This problem's a little bit--
now you're not going to get a
good answer with that unless
you make the conversion.
I pointed it out, the bullet
point in the beginning was
that 1 electron volt is equal
to 1.6 times 10 to minus 19
joules, so if I simply
multiply this by that
conversion, just 1.6 times 10
to the minus 19, this has
units now of joules
per electron volt.
So this has units of joules
The equation turned out
to be pretty long.
But this cancels the electron
volt and now
has units of joules.
Which if you go through the
math, you're going to go ahead
and at the end get a unit
of just meters.
Because joule is just kilogram,
meters squared per
second squared.
So all that factors out and
you end up getting that.
If you go through the math and
you get your math right, then
this should yield a value
of 1.06 times 10
to the minus 9 meters.
So this is the value that
will get you the right
answer on the exam.
Again this is lambda for your
DeBroglie wavelength because
that's what the problem is.
So the problem asked for the
DeBroglie wavelength but it
give you all this information to
get to the point where you
needed to solve.
And by conserving energy and
knowing the right conversion
factors between energies you're
able to get an answer,
which is good.
It's really easy to complicate
things and get a
wrong problem now.
I remember from grading the
exams, the most common error
that people faced was actually
letting the energy of the
electron be the energy
of a photon.
Now that can't be because the
energy of a photon is just
your Planck's Constant
times a frequency.
And that's the energy for
massless particles, your
electron has mass so if
it's moving it's not
going to be h nu.
The energy is going to
be kinetic energy.
1/2 mb squared.
If it's not in an electric
field, that is.
So with that in mind just be
confident when you solve these
problems and make sure that you
know exactly what energy
equations to use to get
the right answer.